I was told to keep this microphone very
close to my face because I think these
are from the 1940s yeah that might be
too close because you're distorting okay
that sounds nice this is good right here
they did Don't Be Afraid okay I don't
know it's just so it's so shiny and it's
uh it's different and I um and my feet
are dangling I feel really weird you
need a little Apple box yeah this is a
little embarrassing we didn't check out
the space beforehand let me set the
table for those of you listening we are
at the uh serious headquarters in Los
Angeles and this is the mothership this
is a beautiful building very high tech
now son and I we've done a show here
before I don't remember your feet
dangling you look like someone just
threw a ventriloquist dummy in a chair
and walked away
um yeah no no no it's fine your feet can
dangle it's fine yeah just be yourself
be relaxed people love you Sona for you
okay yeah I don't know I'm I'm very uh
I'm okay I'm gonna be fine it's just
that it's uh I didn't expect this this
threw me off a little you are you're
fine well my legs are 90 of my body yeah
yeah and I'm over eight feet high okay
now let's talk about Matt Gourley Matt
this is the first time that you've been
in this serious Studios because Sona and
I did a show here once before yeah this
is all new to you yeah this is changing
my life yeah I met someone from Pasadena
yeah there's a woman who came uh to see
the show today I asked the audience just
beforehand who came the farthest
distance this woman very confidently
raised her hand I mean first of all how
would you know you didn't pull the rest
of the audience I think she's right no
we have two people here that uh that
came from Venezuela
yeah they took a boat all the way from
Venezuela she's from Pasadena via the
long way around oh I see we got it uh
but she I asked her she's a Gorly fan oh
and she said and she's a regular
listener to the podcast I kind of
jokingly said if you looked for Matt
Gourley in Pasadena she said she has oh
so she's had her eye out for you but
hasn't seen you yet well vice versa yes
of course and I have noticed a
silhouette in the window at night
it's a respect you're a respectful
stalker
you're a stalker that has principles
no she is she's a covid safe star
Carlos protocol she follows protocol she
always wants to keep a safe distance and
make sure that all the rules are are
followed yes uh well it's uh it's lovely
to have you here I'm meeting some
wonderful people that are in our
audience that's nice
um my life is constantly meeting people
now that listen to the podcast regularly
I've often met people who are in the
process of hearing the podcast on
earbuds
um that's happened to me many times now
uh today was interesting because there's
someone who came all the way here to be
here Robert who uh doesn't has never
heard the podcast before and when I
asked him he made the sort of wavering
hand motion it's the universal signal
known throughout the world is yeah
have you heard a podcast before
oh he said that so confidently like he
listens to every other podcast from this
one I wish Robert had said I do not know
what these podcasts are yeah then I'd
feel better about it all but it turns
out he loves podcast yes
this podcast and he's also he lives with
his wife uh and assuming I'm assuming
you do I only said that because my wife
and I will be no longer live together
her requests we're going to straighten
it out
um I don't blame her no no no one does
everyone's on her side I think let's
just say she had had enough of my banter
she also chooses not to listen to this
part she also yeah yeah or or to me no I
live in a little bouncy castle behind
the house
um but you know that's it fascinates me
that uh wife and Avid fan loves the
podcast
always listening to it and yet that's
really telling that you're living in
close proximity to a Super Fan that
would come to a a a broadcast like this
and yeah a taping like this and yet you
still refuse to listen and I may talk
about nothing else I may not even bring
a guest out today
angry yeah he's also got earplugs in
right now yeah yeah he's like a child
he's got his hands over his ears
Stuck on You
it's very difficult because when I roll
over at night I bounce out through the
top of the castle
dying going going
you could sleep anywhere else whenever I
can always tell that Liza my wife is
annoyed with me because uh she quietly
walks out of the house and then I hear
the sound of a bouncy castle inflating
[Music]
she's doing it manually that's how much
for herself she does it manually yeah oh
man yeah no well she's Amish they don't
believe in using tools I'm married
oh they love bouncy houses yeah but they
do not believe you're learning a lot
about Liza today yeah
she's got incredible lung capacity
they're recruiting her for the uh for
the Olympics so yeah God yeah holding
her breath underwater for hours at a
time uh I'm gonna tell you that I think
that we're going to convert Robert today
but the end of this podcast yeah uh he's
gonna be because already he's like oh my
God this guy where is all this funny
information coming from he must have scr
he just thought of Amish how did he do
that and he's probably freaking out
thinking like when you see a magician
perform you're like what's the trick how
does he do it I think your neediness is
driving him further away from the
podcast I think he's like oh my God is
this what the whole podcast is is it
singling somebody somebody out who
doesn't listen there are 29 super fans
here and all you can think about it let
me explain to the rest of them let me
explain to the rest of you how it works
when you're someone who's Afflicted with
uh whatever it is I have and you see an
audience and everyone's happy except one
person you only think about that one
person and I'll go tonight when I'm in
that bouncy castle trying to fall asleep
slowly uh bouncing up and down I'll be
thinking about robbers how come I
couldn't win Robert over that's the way
it is no that's not that's not healthy
it's not healthy
Robert's got the demeanor of like a dad
from the 1950s when you come over to
date his daughter and you're in high
school and he's just like you got a lot
to prove kid yeah yeah yeah no I saw him
just fish out his uh the his car keys
from his pocket I think he's either
going to attack me with him or drive
away immediately I say listen I am
thrilled that uh we have a great
audience here we're here in this
incredible it's like uh it's it's the
Death Star and I mean that in the nice I
said is that good that's good meaning it
has the capability to destroy planets
and may well maybe it will but also it's
advanced technology Death Star the first
one and the second one
these all run together for me you've
seen one you've seen them all you know
okay let's let's take it easy